I believe that most human beings are
only living at about 40% of their
capability make a dam schedule and stick
to it
okay so what's the rule with the
schedule it's not a bloody prison that's
the first thing that people do wrong and
we live in a world where energy is even
more valuable than it intelligence wanna
be happy
build our life not just the business
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you as
well you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so today let's live
your best believed life and learn how to
develop Spartan discipline
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get in charge of your pain with
David Goggins I believe that most human
beings are only living at about 40
percent of their capability so the mind
has a governor like a car if you're
driving a car and the car has a governor
on it the car may say hundred thirty
miles an hour but the governor set for
ninety one once that governor sets in
you get ninety one that car starts doing
this the car wants to go the car wants
to go but that factory said ah we're not
going past ninety one we have a factory
a nice governor in our brain and it's a
survival mechanism it protects us from
pain and suffering the second we feel
that our mind says no no this isn't fun
we should back off we should sit down
find something more comfortable
and there's something about the mind the
mind has the tactical advantage over you
at all times at all times of your life
the mind has a tactical advantage over
you why is that it knows that you're
afraid of it knows your insecurities and
knows your deep dark lies and it starts
to push you away from that it pushes you
in a direction that is comfortable the
mind controls everything so what I
realized was that when I was growing up
and I was 300 pounds and I got all fat
and I got all insecure I realized that
my mind kept taking me in this direction
when things got uncomfortable for me
when I was facing my insecurities I was
facing my fears my mind said oh no we
have a tactical advantage we just get
you separate you from this feeling this
feeling over your life's all about
feelings we want the happy feeling we
don't want that feeling if this sucks
why am I here and you don't have any
choice or you can't answer those
questions so you leave I started
realizing that if in that moment you can
answer those tough questions and you are
now in charge of your brain versus your
brain ruling you that's where all that
stuff comes from so the 40% rule is all
of that you get to 40% your brain says
we're done let's roll man this is trying
to get painful this is uncomfortable so
you sit down you have to figure out ways
and everybody's different that's how the
book kind of talks about like we all
have these things about you know five
steps to this and four steps to this
it's it's a lot more than that that's
all [ __ ] it's it's a practice that
you have to it's a habit so if you know
that forty percent I'm still you know
I'm feeling pain at 40 percent feeling
pain that's where the 40 percent rule
kicks in now it starts okay I'm feeling
pain my mind's saying all this to me
it's saying get out of here run flee the
fight-or-flight kicks in okay we're
gonna we're not good enough and starts
telling you all these things you start
to believe it because the mind controls
all this is the time where you have to
gain control back of your mind it says
okay let me see if I can go 45 percent
and once you start giving yourself more
and more hope and start realizing okay
the mind starts to be okay what are you
doing we're supposed to be going right
and you're going left you start then
controlling your mind start finding more
in you know in yourself and it goes from
40 percent to a lot further than that
but that's the start of it though get to
get to the spot where your mind is
saying stop wherever that is you gotta
get there first and then that's when
that starts to work for you you got to
control yourself in that moment rule
number 2 make a proper schedule with
Jordan Peterson make a damn schedule and
stick to it okay so what's the rule with
the schedule it's not a bloody prison
that's the first thing that people do
wrong is well I don't like to have
follow a schedule looks like well what
kind of schedule are you setting up well
I should I have to do this then I have
to do this then I have to do this
and then I just go play video games
because who wants to do all these things
that I have to do
it's like wrong set the damn schedule up
so that you have the day you want that's
the trick it's like okay I've got
tomorrow if I was gonna set it up so it
was the best possible day I could have
practically speaking what would it look
like well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's gonna go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're gonna
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that then at the beginning of the
day right cuz that's a stupid day if you
have a bunch of those in a row you just
dig you know you did yourself a hole and
then you bury yourself in it's like
sorry that's just not a good strategy
it's a bad strategy
so maybe 20% of your day has to be
responsibility and obligation or maybe
it's more than that depending on how far
behind you are but even that you can you
can ask yourself okay well I've got
these responsibilities I have to
schedule the damn things in what's the
right ratio of responsibility to reward
and you can ask yourself that just like
you'd negotiate with someone who is
working for you it's like okay you got
work tomorrow okay so I want you to work
tomorrow and you might say okay well
what are you gonna do for me that makes
it likely that I'll work for you well
you could ask yourself that you know
maybe you do an hour of responsibility
and then you play a video game for 15
minutes I don't know whatever turns your
crank man but you know you have to
negotiate with yourself and not
tyrannize yourself like you're
negotiating with someone that you care
for that you would like to be productive
and have a good life and and that's how
you make the schedule it's like and then
you look at the day and you think well
if I had that day that I'd be good great
you know and you you're useless and
horrible so you'll probably only hit it
with about 70% accuracy but that beats
the hell out of zero right and if you
hit it even with 50% accuracy another
rule is well aim for 51% the next week
or 50 and a half percent for God's sake
or because you're gonna hit that
position where things start to loop back
positively and spiral you upward also if
you want to have more confidence check
out my 254 series they're free
linked to Joyner in the description
below you can outwork anybody how bad as
they are freshman year in college me and
my boys start like this like Christian
like organization people want to know
how to stop the laziness and they want
to know how to stop the procrastination
lesson number three have a strong why
with Eric Thomas yo you got to
discipline yourself I started looking at
mother Teresa of Gandhi and I was like
yo bro Gandhi would go fast from sex and
he was married he would fast from
talking you know I just started watching
these great peoples like all these
people fast and not about fast and like
that's not the peace but they were very
disciplined people and they would not
allow their exterior world to dominate
or destroy their internal world I just
like you I want to get to a place where
I can control me my family members have
grown a loss too uncle cirrhosis of the
liver brilliant man but just drinking
drinking drinking and I was like yo I do
not want to my father was a substance
abuser for years I was like yo I don't
want a life where something else is
controlling me
you know like when I left home and said
I don't want to be controlled no more
like I meant that like I don't know
nothing to control me but me and so I
gotta put myself under extreme
discipline to make sure I'm free so when
people see me you get up at 3:00 you
don't drink you don't smoke I'm not
doing that because I think I'm better
than a BYOs oh I think you gonna go to
hell because you had a drink I just want
I want to control I want freedom and for
me disciplining myself means more
freedom and unless I you discipline
yourself people who I told my son other
dads like your son
I don't not want you to have fun I just
seen a history of people who just have
fun Christmas Thanksgiving Halloween
know there are the people learns that
night every night there are the people
who end up in a 20s having a great deal
of fun but in a 40s and 50s they were
working for somebody and I'm not saying
nothing wrong with cleaning toilets but
they doing something they don't want to
do for the rest of day life and they
can't retire because they plays so much
you know so for me I just look at
innocence arena Michael Jackson when he
used to like five and sixes dancing all
night I just think the more man
discipline himself the greater you don't
mean it's gonna happen but the greater
the probability that he has this sense
of freedom rule number four develop a
good morning routine with Robin Sharma
the way you begin each day sets up the
way you live each day I mean the Spartan
warriors set it so well sweat more in
training
bleed lessen war and if you want to be
literally undefeatable in business
literally unstoppable in life you really
want to dial in your morning routine and
so you want to do things like starting
the day sweating because that releases
BDNF brain-derived neurotrophic factor
that repairs brain cells from stress you
want to sweat because that's going to
increase your metabolic rate which is
going to give you energy and we live in
a world where energy is even more
valuable than intelligence you want to
in your morning routine take the time to
write in a journal so you actually can
detect your values reconnect with your
goals each day get to know yourself even
more because awareness is the beginning
of transformation and you want to get
your morning routine right so you take
some time at the front end of your day
to learn because as you learn more you
know you're gonna achieve more and as
you understand better you can achieve
larger and rule number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip is get
discipline with Jocko willing how many
people are like involved in a start-up
right now they're starting up right cool
so I'll start up it's like a little kid
right it's got all this potential it's
got all this potential what happens with
a little kid that never gets disciplined
yeah little kids that don't get
disciplined turning to Satan that's what
happens
and guess what now in the beginning like
a start up like a baby when you got a
baby you got to do everything for it in
the beginning you got a hold it's hid
you got to make sure everything's
perfect the way do whatever it takes to
get that thing keep that thing alive you
got to do it but once that thing starts
to expand well then you better start
imposing some discipline on it or else
that thing will turn into Satan now we
have a special bonus tip from Terrell
Owens on how to outwork everybody that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
is time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking an action here we go
question number 1 where do you need to
get more discipline number 2 how can you
make your morning routine even more
powerful and number 3 what is your
strong and if you promise to take action
after watching this video don't just
watch another video you got to do
something after watching it
give me a hash tag believe in the
comments and make that promise to
yourself then go keep it the third
leading receiver in the history of the
NFL isn't starting as a junior in high
school until a senior not north scenery
you're either
are you kidding though you didn't start
as a senior in high school
Ennis so you obviously Wow like isn't
that a lesson all you young athletes
have follow me hey just because it's not
where it needs to be right now doesn't
mean you can't get there and you want
you entrepreneurs that are following me
that may not be on the varsity of
business yet this is one of the all-time
greats in the history and you're talking
about by that time most guys are being
recruited they got eight nine ten
schools coming after us and that's crazy
so what did you do just like every time
you get an opportunity just took
advantage of it is that what would
happen I did my coach my head coach at
the time Steve Severus he basically and
I get during the course of the school
year we have probably like a 30 to
45-minute period what they call it
enrichment period where we can either
study other you know work on other
subjects kind of to help get your grades
up things that nature I used that time
to go down to lift weights so he
basically went around to against they
sent a
something around to all the teachers
that basically said yeah if a player
wants to go out you know if you guys
grant him let him get a pass to go down
to the weight room or what happened so
that's literally what I did I took that
those moments those 30 45 minutes of
enrichment period talk to the teacher
went down to the weight room and that's
where I started to do put in extra work
just to kind of get myself bigger faster
stronger that always a theme through the
whole 15 years the NFL yes that was the
start of it I was a kid that was a kid
that really that really put in hard work
I wasn't the most athletic I wasn't the
most sought after I wasn't the most
highly recruited a lot of coming out of
high school going into college not only
did I work out in my spare time when I
was in high school those 30 45 minutes
here I didn't go home during the summer
after my freshman sophomore year of
school so I got the key from the
strength and conditioning coach I did
the same thing got the key to the weight
there we go did the same thing I would
go in that's how I got stronger because
I was in there by myself so I had to
lift off by myself yeah I had to be
careful because I was in there by myself
nobody spotted me so that's how I got
stronger so these are some of the things
that I did
unbeknownst to there you go out there in
terms of how I how I made it this is so
good cuz you outworked everybody it's
also the things you do when no one's
watching like when you played all the
things everyone say aw his physique his
physique right now you know where this
comes from it doesn't happen overnight
it's awesome to hear
if you want to know the laws of the
universe that you must know check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there the number one thing
that's gonna change your life the only
thing that will change your life change
your business change your money change
your relationship